[Applause]
[Music]
glad you got that out of your system
right I know why you're happy today
everybody baguettes Trump today
announced a deal to temporarily reopen
the federal government it'll be open for
three weeks
like his casinos and of course no
funding for the wall it's the thing he
said he would never do he just did right
for 35 days he would like there will
never be a deal without wolf ending wolf
Bundy and Nancy Pelosi said oh yeah hold
my beer
but of course Trump always has to frame
everything is a win for him three weeks
to give the wall maybe I'll declare he
says an emergency that's his new
strategy okay three weeks to declare an
emergency he's like the bad guy at the
end of every movie falling off a
skyscraper still yelling [ __ ] on his way
down you may have won this round striker
but up and Pelosi's they're like yippee
ai-yay [ __ ] grabber
[Music]
what's under this a couple of days ago
Trump was talking about this and he said
I'm quoting word for it he said Nancy
Pelosi or as I call her Nancy that's how
bad she is kicking this man's ass his
cutting nickname for her is her name but
he hasn't been idle Trump you came up
with the slogan did you hear that this
week he said build the wall crime will
fall it's it's stupid it's factually
inaccurate so I came up with one that's
so dumb your base will come
[Music]
and Pelosi said you won't get your wall
I've got bigger balls
oh speaking of balls
Trump's ban on transgender people
serving in the military they say that
can be enforced to Supreme that's what
you get when you put Brett Kavanaugh in
the Supreme Court so that that can't be
enforced and Trump's you know Trump has
always had it out right for the
transgender people on why he told us
today he said no one wants to grab a
[ __ ] and get a surprise
but let's not bury what's most important
in America everyone is talking about the
smirk heard round the world you saw this
kid this week member this kit yeah you
don't know what this is if you're living
under a rock okay here's what happened
this was at the Lincoln Memorial this is
on the mall but of course at the mall in
Washington there's all kinds of people
protesting and there were three groups
there that day that got into it there
was the black Hebrew Israelites there's
not many of them they say there aren't
they live in New York I remember they
stand on the corner calling white people
crackers and they finally got some
attention they believe African Americans
are the literal descendants of the
Israelites in the Bible except we have
DNA and they're not they did 23andme and
it came back you're kidding right but
but the black Hebrew started to mix it
up with these Catholic high school kids
who were there from Kentucky right okay
and they were there with a big pro-life
March and then a Native American elder
playing a drum got in the middle to
mediate and now it's a big thing and you
know people saying the kid the kid I
don't blame the kid the smirking kid
I blame lead poisoning and bad parenting
and oh yeah I blame that [ __ ] kid
what a little smirk face smoke faces
like that's not a chick move at any age
stick your face in this elderly man and
this smirking kid says he was just
trying to defuse the situation but
really you know what next time you get
into a fight with your wife or your
husband or your boyfriend of your
girlfriend try that trace just from
their face with a shit-eating grin it's
even defuses the situation yes
he asked me this kid should have done
what everyone does during a drum solo
leave
but I mean I don't spend a lot of time I
must tell you around Catholic school
children but I do not get what Catholic
priests seeing these kids
[Applause]
but big news Roger stone today was
arrested former gas Trump's first and
greatest political booster he's been
trying to make Donald Trump president
since 1988 he's go to jail just for that
but I mean he is a true believer you
know this a [ __ ] of this political
savvy crowd knows is he has a giant
tattoo of Richard Nixon covering his
entire back that's true I feel sorry for
his cellmate try to keep an erection
looking at that
you